Blaine you came to Los Angeles in the
90s um yes I did I graduated high school
and I moved to New York where I went to
a acting conservatory that didn't agree
with me so I ended up leaving day after
about six months and then I moved le and
I've been out here ever since what
wasn't about the conservatory that did
you well you know I I had been lucky
enough to do some acting work as a kid
you know so I'd done a couple of TV
movies and stuff and I just come off
this project where i worked with tommy
lee jones and sam sheppard and frances
mcdormand educational experience and we
were on location so like they were
forced to hang out with me and you know
talked a lot about going to college and
you know doing a regular proper
education and not just acting school and
so when I got this conservatory was
pretty much just an acting school and I
wanted more and you know it was because
of those people that I admired and you
know wanted to be like telling me that
you get to get a proper education stuff
that I ended up coming back to LA and
you know pursuing acting and stuff but
while I was doing that I went to UCLA
and got majored in English literature
political science so which I think has
made me the person I am today well
that's interesting because you started
out as an actor but then you've
transitioned to writing alright so can
you tell us about that well yeah it was
basically it was a my roommate now both
actors and we weren't getting the parts
that we wanted to get you know we
weren't even going up for them but all
the things we were auditioning for the
scripts were terrible so it's other
rider myself microphone call it was our
first grip either of us when we wrote
this script together and somehow we
ended up getting a director attached and
getting financing and end up going and
it became this movie called manic that
start Don Cheadle and just gordon-levitt
and Zooey Deschanel and yeah and so
suddenly I was a writer you know I was a
kid didn't really know much but I've
written this this movie so basically I
became a writer because I wanted better
material to act in so from there I you
know with bright things that
didn't act in you know do rewrites for
hire that kind of thing and then I
became a director because i didn't like
a director that directed one of my
scripts you know and i'm like well he's
going to screw it up i can screw it up
less than he did so then i became a
director so it's it's funny it's like
the road of an actor but it has led to
so many different things well what's
your take on that because so many actors
can come here from other places and they
rely on the system right to get them in
whether it's the acting the casting
websites whether it's a manager whatever
but I've heard from so many people that
they just want to wrote their own work
they did that so what's a vehicle people
that wait around forever for someone
else I just think it's not I don't know
what the business used to be like but I
know now with like digital and like you
know our ability to make something it'll
pretty low budget it's uh I think it's a
huge blunder not to take advantage of
that and go after it um I certainly
wouldn't be where I am now if I'd waited
for someone to you know hire me to do
some studio to come out and say oh here
you go plain weave or do this you know
you like you do your own stuff and you
know either it works out or doesn't but
you end up learning something along the
way like you know I think it is a
business but it's also art you know and
there's something really to be said for
like if you're an artist do your art you
know don't just wait you know to get
handed you know the plum role sometimes
it works out that way for people but I
found it on the whole its people to go
after it
you